I started venture from America in 2011
help train young entrepreneurs to start
companies and create jobs in Detroit New
Orleans Baltimore Cleveland Birmingham
and other cities around the country
because I had the sense that that we had
too much talent getting concentrated on
Wall Street and in Silicon Valley and
not enough creating new enterprises
around the country and what I learned
during that period was that we're
automating away many many more jobs than
entrepreneurs are gonna create in
Michigan Ohio Missouri and on and on
it's like we were pouring water to a
bathtub that has a giant hole ripped in
the bottom and so then you say okay like
what the heck do you do about the hole
on the bathtub and Donald Trump getting
elected in 2016 what was a like a giant
signal to me where things have gotten so
bad with the decimation of manufacturing
jobs in Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania
Wisconsin which were the swing states he
needed to win we automated way four
million jobs in those states automated
away four million jobs in those states
15 we automated away four million
manufacturing jobs and in those states
and around the country and if you look
at the voter district data there's a
direct correlation between the number of
industrial robots in a district and then
the movement toward Trump so this is all
a giant automation and economic shift
story and for whatever reason it's it's
like our media is out to lunch on it
where they talk to like oh why did Trump
win like the reason he won is that we've
automated away millions of manufacturing
jobs and we're here in Silicon Valley
right now my friends here know we're
about to do the same thing to workers
and retail truck driving call centers
pass food on and on throughout the
economy so yeah I mean it's it is like
you said at the moment this is the
moment for Humanity to come together and
start owning what's happening